eleven-year-old adarian Murray still has
bandages where he was shot in the chest
Saturday by an Indianola Mississippi
police officer he didn't know at the
moment that he was shot his mother
Nakayla Murray remembers the chaos and
confusion while holding her bleeding son
he was he started singing gospel he
started praying we started praying we're
very religious did you think your son
was gonna die
Murray says she asked her son to call
9-1-1 after an Irate ex-boyfriend showed
up to her house around 4 a.m Saturday
morning when Indianola police arrived
family attorney Carlos Moore says
officers banged on the door and told
everyone to exit the house as a Darion
was following that order he went out of
his room and went twice the living room
as soon as he got a living room he got
shot by that same officer that told him
to come out he didn't have anything in
his hands or armed or nothing he had
nothing